nous avons pris les dispositions
nécessaires pour dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale et déclencher des élections
générales
c'est quoi notre message c'est que
ensemble on s'occupe de quoi des vraies
affaires
c'est se donner un signal de se donner
le go arrêté tourner en rond j'en ai
assez moi ça fait des décennies que ça
dure au québec ce gouvernement ce parti
politique continue à présenter les
québécois comme des gens affirme
assiéger menacé faire du québec un pays
le parti québécois vient de choisir l'un
des patrons les plus intransigeants les
plus anti travailleurs du québec avec le
gouvernement la prochaine élection porte
sur l'élection d'un gouvernement qui va
qui offre aux québécois et aux
québécoises un plein responsable une
vision une perspective et nous sommes
capables aussi de discuter de l'avenir
du québec ce que nous ferons par un
livre blanc sur l'avenir du québec jean
carmet électorale pour empêcher bien
j'ai vu les sondages map m
et on est dans une situation où une côte
à remonter les trois depuis le départ de
la charnie l'époque on utilisait les
québécois l'arrivée de pierre karl
péladeau a pas de nier a eu pas eu un
impact considérable je le sais bien
c'était ce qu'on souhaitait c'est ce
qu'on savait aussi et la madame marois
se reconnaît dans un an et demi plus
tard a dit aux québécois faites moi
confiance
jamais de la vie on veut revenir à ce
qu'on a connu
sous monsieur charest même vision même
équipe même perspective mais un problème
d'éthique moi j' aborderai pas ces
questions avec eux si elle choisit de
faire au débat un vrai couteau
allez vous oui ou non tenez un
référendum dans le prochain mandat
il y en aura pas de référendum demain
matin puis vous le savez très bien tenté
québécois seront pas prêts et en europe
on fera pas sans cachettes combien de
femmes dans nos hôpitaux dans nos écoles
mano solo de gamme mais vous faire
congédier vous intéresse nos clients
- il ya une seule femme que j'ai vu
perdre son emploi au québec on perde sa
fonction c'est fatima houda-pepin la
question de l'élection sans gouvernement
pour un référendum ou à grenoble pour
l'économie n'a après la pause puis tout
ce qui lui reste à monsieur couillard
cette faille pas aux québécois avec le
référendum si si vous voulez un
changement si vous voulez reconnaît que
les neuf années libéral ont donné de la
merde qu'on a actuellement ben changé ah
ça y est notre essair un garage la boue
c'est ça la tournée
ok ça lire pour se faire élire moi je
vois qu'on vole pour gagner c'est comme
ça que je veux faire et un sujet a
dominé tous les autres celui du compte
détenu par philippe couillard vous en
parlait hier je connais pas dit monsieur
couillard c'est que je compte était dans
l'île de jersey située entre
l'angleterre et la france inscrits
jusqu'à récemment sur la liste noire des
paradis fiscaux
à moins qu'on va changer les lois
fiscales ce sont les règles et elle
s'appelait on voudrait confier la
direction de notre gouvernement à
quelqu'un qui ne voit aucun problème à
ce que des citoyens à y placer leur
argent dans les paradis fiscaux c'est
moral pour vous il ya peu près le régime
fiscal à moins qu'on dise qu'il est
immoral qu'on veuille de changer c'est
la façon dont on le régime fiscal
fonctions je suis estomaqué monsieur
bruno d'entendre monsieur couillard ce
soir nous dire que y'a pas de problème
de français au québec side c'est
dangereux alors prévenons en ayant une
charte
on sent sur le terrain
un vent de changement moi j'veux plus
optimiste que jamais d'avoir un
gouvernement
la cohésion avenir québec tient à ce
point cette charte que c'est vous allez
vers la dérogation nous le ferons l'esp
ordinaire on nous apprend que la charte
été programmés pour échouer devant les
tribunaux et créer une crise qui
servirait par la suite de combustible
pour le référendum
j'ai dit ce que j'avais à azay sur
l'achat et du mans bat pied pas là
dedans
moi je vois parler d'économie jusqu'à
lundi prochain nous sommes actuellement
devant une élection va choisir un
gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas en élection pour
décider qu'il ya un référendum parce que
qui est un bar et ont reçu le 1.2
million pour service pour baba futur je
vous parie que si monsieur barrette a
été candidate monsieur legault il ne
serait pas question dans sa bouche
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on fait un virage
même si on fait comme philippe couillard
on paye sur l'accélérateur pour un peu
plus d'ampleur
je prends rien pour acquis mais je crois
que le 7 au soir à gouvernement libéral
moi je travaille pour gagner 17 avril
prochain